was that you must be new that is first
Wayne
this away Clark Kent Daily Planet what's
your position on the bat vigilante in
Gotham
civil liberties are being trampled on in
their city people living in fear thinks
he's above the law a Daily Planet
criticizing those just think they're
above the laws Oh hypocritical put your
self considering every time your hero
saves the cat out of a tree you're a
tough piece sanitorium
about an alien it could burn the whole
place down most of the world doesn't
share your opinion mr. Wayne
maybe it's Gotham City and me you just
have a bad history with freaks dressed
like clowns
boys Oh Bruce Wayne meets Clark Kent I
love it
I love bringing people together how are
we looks hi hello Lex it is a pledge out
wow that is a good grip you should not
pick a fight with this person you know
the oldest lie in America senator the
power can be innocent
he's the one that brought the war to us
you know you can't win this it's suicide
the greatest gladiator match in the
history of the world
Son of Krypton versus bat of God
you're psychotic it's a three syllable
word for any thought too big for little
minds
it's time you learned what it means to
be a man
I wanted it you'll be dead already
man will kill God
the demo will kill it
what have you done
she would you I thought she was here
you
you